Ich würde mit Ihnen das Aufnommen Gespräch führen.
Bevor wir anfangen, möchte ich Ihnen eine Frage zu Ihrer Person stellen.
Sind Sie da mit einverstanden?
Ja.
Wie heißen Sie da?
Ich heiße Peter Lindemann.
Peter Lindemann.
Lindemann mit R, oder?
Lindemann.
Wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 60 Jahre alt.
Wann sind Sie denn born?
Am 12. April 1965.
1965, gut.
Wie sind Sie aktuell? Wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin 1,84 m groß.
84 m groß, ja.
Wie viel sind Sie?
93 kg.
Vielen Dank, Herr Lindemann.
Was kann ich für Sie tun?
Was für mich werden Sie?
Seit zwei Tagen fühle ich mich sehr krank, sehr müde.
Ich habe Husten, Muskelschmerzen,
Gelenkschmerzen, Muskelschmerzen.
Wie hoch war Ihr Temperatur?
Ich habe gemessen, 39.
Wo haben Sie Ihre Temperatur gemessen?
Im Mund.
Im Mund, wann genau?
Das letzte Mal war das vor zwei Stunden.
Vor zwei Stunden.
Und haben Sie dagegen etwas angenommen?
Nein, noch nicht.
Okay.
Brauchen Sie Schmerzmitteil oder Analyse gegen die hochte Fieber?
Nein, ich brauche nichts.
Wenn das nicht so lange dauert, dann brauche ich nichts.
Vielen Dank.
Ich beine mich.
Nach dem Unterzuch kann ich Ihnen gerne eine Schmerzmitteil geben.
Aber nach dem Unterzuch.
Herr Lindermann, Sie haben seit zwei Tagen Fieber-Müdigkeit Husten.
Haben Sie Auswurf?
Ja, da kommt auch von Husten etwas raus.
Das sieht so gelblich bräunlich aus.
Gelblich bräunlich.
Okay.
Gibt es jemand in Ihrer Umgebung,
in der ich nicht beschwerden?
Nein, nein.
Ich bin nicht beschwerd.
Herr Ste, gibt es keine?
Was machen Sie beruflich?
Ich möchte wissen.
Ich bin Taxifahrer.
Keine.
Deswegen, Sie müssen viele Menschen kontakten, oder?
Ja, ja.
Und viele sind krank.
Ja, Herr Ste, viele krank.
Sie sind 60 Jahre alt.
Und haben Sie vielleicht ein Test gemacht über Covid-19?
Ich habe bisher keine Tests gemacht.
Okay, verstehe.
Ich möchte wissen, ob Sie gegen Covid-19
oder jährliche Influenza-Infungen gemacht haben.
Ja, habe ich regelmäßig gemacht.
Ich habe ein Termin beim Hausarzt für nächste Woche.
Okay, Influenza-Infungen.
Aber Sie sind gerade krank.
Es ist nicht richtig.
Sie müssen nicht die Influenza-Infungen bekommen,
weil Sie krank und Fieber haben.
Herr Lindermann, Sie haben Fieber,
Rusten und Auswurf, aber keine Blut-Infung.
Nur jährliche Brownische.
Blut habe ich nicht gesehen.
Okay, verstehe.
Ist Ihnen übel?
Nein, übel ist mir nicht.
Aber ich habe keinen Appetit.
Mit dem Fieber habe ich keinen Hunger.
Verstehe.
Haben Sie in letzter Zeit abgenommen?
Nein, habe mein Gewicht gehalten.
Ich verstehe.
Haben Sie in letzter Zeit Grippe oder Erkältung gehabt?
Nein.
Nein, verstehe.
Sag mir bitte, ob Sie in letzter Zeit gereist haben?
Gerreist?
Ja, Ausland, ich meine, vielleicht.
Ausland? Ja, ich war in Spanien.
Ich war schon 3 Monate hier.
Da war ich 2 Wochen in Spanien.
Vor 2 Wochen?
Nein, vor 3 Monaten.
Vor 2 Wochen lang.
2 Wochen.
Wie war das?
Gut.
2 Wochen dauert.
Sie haben Fieber.
Leiden Sie unter Nachtschweiß oder Schüttelfrost?
Schüttelfrost nicht, aber in der letzten Nacht habe ich ziemlich stark geschwitzt.
In der letzten Nacht.
Okay, in der letzten Zeit.
In der vielleicht 2 Tage, oder?
Nein, nur in der letzten Nacht war das stärker.
Schüttelfrost keine.
Schlafen Sie?
Nein, ich habe nicht geschlafen.
Ich habe nicht geschlafen.
Ein Schlaf oder Duschlappprobleme?
Beides.
Beides Probleme.
Sie haben keine Appetit mehr.
Schlappprobleme.
Gewiss aber stabil.
Ein Schlafen?
Nein.
Müssen Sie in der Nacht Wasser lassen?
Normalerweise.
Normalerweise kann ich wieder gut einschlafen.
Aber die letzten 2 Nächte.
Aber wegen dieser Nächte.
Sie haben einen Arzt aufgesucht?
Ich war schon mal bei der Sorge.
einen erst aufgesucht. Ich war schon mal bei einem Urologen, der hat gesagt, ja die Prostata ist etwas
vergrößert, aber nicht sehr stark und wenn mich das nicht sehr stört, dann kann man erst mal
abwarten. Abwarten, aber Sie haben nicht dagegen eine Tabletin. Nein, nein. Okay. Seit wann leiden Sie an
Prostata? Na bekannt ist das glaube ich seit drei Jahren. Seit drei Jahren.
Herr Lindemann, haben Sie früher eine Küstenmütigkeit, Fieber, vielleicht seit drei Monaten lang?
Nein, ich habe in den letzten Jahren häufiger im Winter, habe ich häufiger
fieberhafte Bronchitis. Das habe ich häufiger in den letzten Jahren gehabt, im letzten Winter zweimal,
da musste ich immer ein Antibiotikum nehmen, aber jetzt ist das viel schlimmer. Jetzt fühle ich mich
viel schlechter. Zwei Mal, letzte Jahr Antibiotikum. Aber jetzt schlimmer. Wie so jetzt schlimmer?
Ja, weil das Fieber höher ist, normal das viel höher und ich fühle mich so, meine Muskeln tun
so wie und meine Gelenke schmerzen und ich habe ja auch Schmerzen beim Atmen und das war die
anderen Zeit nicht. Das ist jetzt neu. Okay, diese Schmerzen, meine Sie auch die Brustschmerzen?
Nein, Brustschmerzen nicht. Am Rücken hinten tut es beim Einatmen weh. Das tut mir sehr weh und das
ist am Rücken so in Höhe vom Schulterblatt hinten. Das tut sehr weh, das ist sehr unangenehm.
Gibt es keine Wunde oder? Nein, keine Verletzung. Aber nur einatmen, während einatmen haben
sich Schmerzen oder Ausatmen. Wenn ich tief einatmen, tief, dass du sehr weh oder wenn ich
husten musst, das ist auch sehr unangenehm. Okay, und beim Husten. Und wie stark sind die Schmerzen?
Nein, ich möchte fragen, wie stark sind die Schmerzen? Ich habe das nicht verstanden. Können Sie das noch
für meine Begründung? Ich möchte fragen, wie stark sind die Schmerzen, die Schulterblattschmerzen? Auf
einer Schmerzkala von 1 bis 10, von 1 bis Leiter, 10 sehr stark Schmerzen bedeutet. Ich würde sagen 5 bis 6.
5 bis 6. Bitte beschreiben Sie die Schmerzen, sind vielleicht steckende, ziehen die Schmerzen?
Ja, mehr stechend. Wenn ich tief einatme, dann ist es ein stechender Schmerz.
Okay, Herr Lindemann, haben Sie noch andere Wüchler, wie ich wissen sollte?
Gusten, Fieber, Schmerzen im Rücken, Muskelschmerzen, Gelenkschmerzen, ja, das sind meine akuten Beschwerden.
Verstehe. Herr Lindemann, ihr rauchen Sie vielleicht, oder?
Ja, ich rauche. Wie viele Zigarette rauchen Sie täglich?
Ich rauche ungefähr eine Schachtel pro Tag, aber auch schon seit 35 Jahren.
35 Jahren, oh, es ist zu viel. Aber Sie versuchen mit dem Rachen aufzuhören?
Ja, habe ich schon zweimal versucht, über Kurse mit der Krankenkasse und mit Nikotinpflaster,
habe ich schon probiert. Aber mein Beruf ist sehr stressig als Taxifahrer.
Es ist schwierig mit dem Rauchen. Ich weiß, dass es nicht gesund, aber...
Ja, ich verstehe Herr Lindemann, aber es gibt viele Möglichkeiten, um die Stressreduzierung.
Wenn Sie Hilfe brauchen, wir sind für Sie immer da.
Danke. Herr Lindemann, leiden Sie an chronische Erkrankungen außer prostatäipätri.
Ja, einmal diese Bronchitis, die wird so von Jahr zu Jahr, wird die eher schlimmer.
Da hat mein Arzt schon gesagt, das hängt mit dem Rauchen zusammen,
dass ich an chronische Bronchitis jetzt vielleicht bekomme.
Ich habe hohe Cholesterin. Ja, das geht schon so drei Jahre.
Ich habe hohe Cholesterinwerte. Seit fünf Jahren, da nehme ich auch ein Medikament.
Und ich habe hohe Harnsäurewerte.
Seit drei Jahren, da hatte ich auch schon zweimal einen Gichtanfall.
Am großen Zähgelenk, an der großen Zähle.
Zweimal Gichtanfall.
Seit zwei Jahren hat meine Hausärztin festgestellt,
ist mein Zucker immer leicht an der Grenze.
Sie sagt auch, das müssen wir genauer untersuchen,
aber ich habe das bisher noch nicht so ernst genommen.
Okay, haben Sie vielleicht eine Tis gemacht dafür?
Blutes haben wir gemacht.
Ja, da sagt sie, der Zucker ist an der Grenze.
Und eigentlich sagt sie, muss ich etwas Gewicht abnehmen.
Das fällt mir aber schwer, weil ich viel sitze beim Beruf als Taxifahrer.
Ich bewege mich nicht viel.
Ja, ich weiß das Problem.
Herr Lindermann, noch andere Erkrankungen, die ich wissen sollte?
Nein.
Wurden Sie sich schon einmal operiert?
Ja, als Kind wurde ich an den Mandeln operiert.
Da war ich zehn Jahre alt.
Und dann wurde ich als Kind, da war ich zwölf, am Leistenbruch operiert,
auf der rechten Seite.
Leistenbruch?
Ja, dann hatte ich im Alter von, da war ich 30 Jahre alt.
Beim Fußballspielen hatte ich einen Knöchelbruch,
linker Knöchel am Sprunggelenk.
Weil ich nicht aus operiert werde.
Linken Knöchelbruch.
Okay.
Haben Sie wegen dieser Operationen irgendwelche Komplikationen gehabt?
Nein.
Okay.
Und aktuell haben Sie Knöchelbruch und die andere Brüche irgendwelche beschwerden?
Nein.
Nein, das ist alles okay geworden.
Sehr gut.
Und Herr Lindermann, nehmen Sie regelmäßig oder bei Bedarf Medikamenten?
Ja, einmal für Cholesterin.
Das heißt Simvastatin.
Ja, wie viel Milligramm?
Dahinter steht 20.
Okay, nehmen Sie abends einmal.
Abends eine Tablette.
Sehr gut.
Und sonst noch andere?
Dann nehme ich noch Alupurinol.
300 Milligramm, das ist 300 Milligramm.
Dann nehme ich morgens eine Tablette.
Morgen.
Mhm.
Sonst noch andere?
Nee, sonst nichts.
Sehr gut.
Sie ist allergischgegenetwas?
Allergie keine.
Nein.
Und haben Sie Unverträglichkeiten?
Und Medikamentalergie, oder?
Sehr gut.
Trinkln Sie regelmäßig Alkohol?
Nein, nicht regelmäßig.
Ich bin ja Taxifahrer.
Da muss ich immer aufpassen.
Mal trinke ich ein kleines Flasche Bier, aber das ist vielleicht 2 Mal lieber.
Ein kleines 2-mal Flasche Bier.
2 Mal in der Woche.
Kleines 1,3.
Ja, 0,3.
0,3, okay.
Sehr gut.
Und bitte nehmen Sie sonstige Drogen?
Nein.
Okay, super.
Und leben Ihre Eltern noch?
Sind Sie gesund, Herr Lindermann?
Also, die Mutter lebt noch.
Die ist 82 Jahre alt.
82 Jahre alt?
Hat hohen Blutdruck.
Und hat Alterszucker.
Der Vater.
Sie haben auch, vielleicht,
aber nicht Grenze.
Der Vater ist verstorben im Alter von 80 Jahren.
An Lungenkrebs.
Lungenkrebs, es tut mir sehr leid zu hören.
Und haben Sie Geschwister?
Ja, eine Schwester, die 57 Jahre alt, die wurde vor 2 Jahren
an Brustkrebs operiert.
Vor 2 Jahren?
Ja, und anschließend bekam sie noch Chemotherapie.
Aber bei der Beide geht es ganz gut.
Links.
Okay, links Seite.
Und vielleicht operiert, oder?
Ja, ja.
Und Chemotherapie.
Sehr gut.
Und Sie sind Taxifahrer.
Ja, ich habe noch einen Bruder.
Ich habe noch einen Bruder.
Der ist 45 Jahre alt.
Wie alt ist der?
55.
Ja, und?
Und der hat hohen Blutdruck.
Okay.
Und Sie sind verheiratet?
Ja.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, 2 Kinder, 30 und 32 Jahre alt.
Sie sind gesund?
Sie sind gesund, ja.
Sehr gut.
Wollen Sie mit Ihrem Familien zusammen?
Nein, nur mit meiner Frau.
Die Kinder wohnen in anderen Städten.
Wollen Sie mit Frau verstehen?
Herr Lindemar, haben Sie gegene, Sie haben gesagt,
im Funken aber vielleicht die anderen Kindererkrankheit
...
nicht.
Sie haben schon
Da hatte ich gehabt als Kind, aber nicht de bangserie.
Da bin ich überall geimpft.
Und da achtet auch meine Hausärztin drauf,
dass ich regelmäßig auffrisch empfungen mache.
Super.
Herr Lindemar, ich bin fertig.
Villen Sie etwas generates怎樣 zu fragen.
kann ich haben? Was kann das sein? Das Fieber habe ich ja noch nie gehabt und auch diese Schmerzen
hinten da am Schulterblatt. Das ist unangenehm. Ich muss sofort bei Ihnen körperliche Untersuchung
durchführen. Ich höre sofort Ihren Lunge ab und ein bisschen Blut abnehmen und sonst kann
Torax veranlassen. Was heißt Torax? Torax, ja, Brustkopf, ich meine. Achso, Brustkopf, ja, okay. Lunge,
Röntgen, Lungen. Und danach können wir noch mal darüber sprechen. Ich denke, Sie haben vielleicht
noch mal Brunchitis oder mehr, chronische Brunchitis oder auch die Lungen-Enschnung. Achso, ja, das muss
natürlich festgestellt werden. Ja, deswegen brauche ich weitere Untersuchungen. Okay, das gern wir so machen.
Gut, dann haben Sie jetzt etwas Zeit und Kolleginnen und Kollegen können gerne Fragen
stellen, vielleicht noch Zusatzfragen oder wenn wir irgendetwas vergessen haben.
Haben Sie gerötete Geschwollene oder warme Beine bemerkt? Nein, habe ich nicht. Ne, meine Beine sind normal,
wie immer. Geschwollen sind die auch nicht. Wie viel Kissen haben Sie in der Nacht benutzt? Auf denen ich schlafe,
Kissen, 1 bis 2, aber ja, 1 bis 2. Okay, danke schön. Haben Sie Stuhlgangstörungen? Nein, mein Stuhlgang ist regelmäßig, da habe ich keine Probleme mit.
Okay, keine Obstfraktion. Okay, danke schön. Okay, ich lasse Sie jetzt mal fünf Minuten alleine,
dann können Sie sich gut vorbereiten. Ja, und dann komme ich gleich wieder. Ja.
Was meinen Sie? Können Sie nicht Vorstellung machen? Ja, natürlich. Sehr gut.
Schönen guten Abend Herr Oberass, ich habe einen neuen Patientin, den ich Ihnen vorstellen möchte.
Haben Sie Moment Zeit dafür? Ja, habe ich. Vielen Dank. Es geht um Herrn Peter Lindemann.
Er ist 60 Jahre alt, geboren am 12. April 1965. Er ist 84 groß und wiegt er zu seit 93 Kilogramm.
Okay. Herr Lindemann stelle sich bei uns heute vor, weil er seit zweit sagen an
Müdigkeit oder Fatigue, Husten mit Ausfurcht leidet. Er berichtete, dass er
inspiratorische Schmerzen in den rechten Schulterblatt hat. Man kann auch sagen, er berichtet über
einen inspiratorischen, besonders inspiratorischen Schmerz, rechts Dorsal in Höhe der Skapula.
Er weiß nicht genau, dass es im Höhe des Schulterblatt ist, aber Sie haben auch gesagt,
rechts Schulterblatt, sagen Sie ruhig rechts Dorsal, dann haben wir den Rücken, Dorsum, der Rücken und
in Höhe der Skapula. Meine Kommentare ist falsch. Nein, nein, nicht falsch.
Falsch ist es nicht, aber so haben wir etwas mehr Fachsprache.
Rechts Dorsal in Höhe der, ja, ich habe Schulterblatt gesagt, sie haben nicht.
Hat er sonst Schmerzen, Muskelschmerzen, Gelenkschmerzen?
Ja, natürlich. Er hatte auch Mialgi, Atralgi und typische Grippale Entzündungssymptomatik.
Okay, und diesen inspiratorischen Schmerz rechts Dorsal, ne?
Gut, waren Sie bitte fort.
Ja, darüber hinaus leide er an, er höchte Fibar 39 Grad Celsus, die im Mund gemessen hat.
Ja, sagen Sie lieber Oral gemessen, Oral.
Oral, ja, ja, Oral, ja.
Oral.
Kann man ihm nicht sagen.
Und desweiteren klackte er über nach Schweiß und in Appätenz.
Okay, gut.
Der Auswurf der, das Expektoranz, das Sekret, was er aushustet, wie sieht das aus?
Ja, der Auswurf sagt, der ist nicht geblieben und bräunlich.
Okay, gut.
Die Frage nach Hemoptöe, Vertigo, Nausea und Nausea wurden verneint.
Aber laut dem Patienten, habe sei er ein Taxifahrer, deswegen musste er viele Menschen kontakten.
Okay.
Ja.
Die vegetative Anamnese, ja, ein Moment, er habe erwähnt, dass er in letzten Jahre,
in Bronschitis gehabt und musste damals zweimal Antibiotikum behandelt wurden.
Man kann sagen, er berichtet, dass er besonders in der Winterzeit, im Winter, in den letzten Jahren,
mehrfach fieberhafte Bronschitis hatte oder eine fieberhafte Bronschitis hatte, die mit Antibiotika behandelt werden musste.
Ja, okay.
Okay, super.
Kann ich noch mal sagen?
Ja, bitte.
Er berichtete, dass er letzte Jahr, im Winter, im Winter, im Winter, mehrfach fieberhafte Bronschitis hatte, die gehabt habe und musste er mit Antibiotikum behandelt werden.
Okay, behandelt werden, ja, okay.
Die vegetative Anamnese ist nachfällig bis auf Nekturi wegen Beninprostata hyperplase.
Okay.
Zu den Vorerkrankungen, gab er an Beninprostata hyperplase, Bronschitis, seit drei Jahren, Hypercholestrimnemi seit fünf Jahren,
Hypercholestrimnemi seit drei Jahren, und er habe zweimal Podogra gehabt.
Podagra.
Ja, sehr gut, sehr gut.
Podagra gehabt.
Und seit zwei Jahren habe er auch begrenzte Zuckerwerte.
Ja, man kann sagen grenzwert, einen grenzwert Diabletus an der Grenze.
Grenzwert Diabletus.
Okay.
Ja, mmh, gehabt.
Er wurde mit in Alter von zehn Jahren Tonselektomie.
Ja, okay.
Und in Alter von zwölf Jahren, rechtsseitige Ingwünalherne, leist im Ingwünalherne, Ingwünilich,
wie kann man sagen, Ingwünalherne-Ophe, medizinische Fachbegriffe.
Ja, man sagt der Begriff heißt Herneotomie.
Herneotomie.
Man kann sagen, im Alter von zwölf Jahren erfolgte eine Herneotomie.
Und Ingwünalherne.
Ingwünalherne.
Okay.
Darüber hinaus habe er in Alter von 30 Jahren nach einem Fußballspiel linksseitige Sprunggelenkfraktur.
Sprunggelenk, oder?
Man kann sagen Sprunggelenkfraktur.
Deswegen musste er operiert.
Ja, er folgte eine Ostiosynthese.
Okay, das waren die drei Operationen.
Tonselektomie, Herneotomie und Ostiosynthese.
Okay.
Er nehmt regelmäßig 17, 20 Milligramm einmal abends.
Und alle neun, 300 Milligramm morgens ein.
Er habe keine Allergie und Unfertigkeiten.
Aber er rauchert zu viel Zigaretten übermäßige Nikotin-Abusus.
35 Packages.
Ja, 35 Packages.
Ja, die können auch sagen, es besteht ein erheblicher oder ausgeprägter Nikotin-Abusus.
Ein ausgeprägter oder starker Nikotin-Abusus von 35 Packages.
Ja, starker Nikotin-Abusus von 35 Packages.
Warum regeln wir nicht 5 Jahre?
5 Jahre falsch?
Nein, ist nicht falsch.
Nein.
Alles gut. Können Sie auch sagen.
Er trinken 2 Mal provokte 0,3 Milliliter Flaschen, Flasche biop.
Ja, eine ist gut.
Das ist nicht so viel.
Ich habe die Familie der Anwesenden von Ergab.
Seine Mutter leidet an Arterieli-Hypertoni und Diabetes-Meldestübzulai.
Wie alt ist die Mutter?
Sie ist 83 Jahre alt.
Sein Vater ist verstorben an Lungenkrebs, aber daran 80 Jahre alt.
Ja, man kann sagen, der Vater ist im Alter von 80 Jahren an einem wohl pulmonalkarzinom.
Aber möglichst nicht Lungenkrebs, sagen Sie möglichst Karzinom.
Entweder Ponchal oder Pulmonalkarzinom.
Wir haben eine Geschichte.
Hat der Geschwister?
Er hatte ein Schwester.
Sie ist 52 Jahre alt.
57?
Sie leidet an Brustkrebs links.
Sie war operiert.
Sie hatte auch Chemotherapie bekommen.
Brustkrebs gibt es eine Medizin.
Und Mama Karzinom.
Er hatte auch einen Bruder, der ist 55 Jahre alt.
Sie hat eine 57-jährige Schwester, die vor zwei Jahren an einem Mama Karzinom operiert wurde.
Sie hat eine Chemotherapie.
Dann haben Sie alles in einem Satz.
Super, danke.
Er ist vollständig geimpft.
Wir müssen fragen, die Difterie und die Difterie.
Die Difterie ist wichtig.
Aber Keuchhusten, Pertussis, ist wieder im Seniorenalter eine ernstzunehmende Erkrankung.
Leider wird ein Keuchhusten, eine Pertussis, im Seniorenalter oft übersehen.
Die Leute werden immer wegen Husten behandelt, bekommen Hustensaft und Hustentabletten.
Dabei haben diese Menschen Keuchhusten, Pertussis.
Weil die Immunität im Alter gegenüber dem Pertussis, was sie als Kinder hatten,
hat einen Les nach.
Deswegen brauchen Erwachsene im Seniorenbereich auch eine Pertussis-Impfung.
Das wird oft übersehen.
Eine hohe Dunkelziffer.
Da muss man auch noch mal die Pertussis-Impfung.
Es gibt einen Impfstoff in Deutschland, der hat eine Kombination.
Die gibt es nur eine Kombination mit Tetanus, Tifterie und der Impfstoff heißt dann Bustrix.
Bustrix.
S-T-R-I-X, das ist ein dreifach Impfstoff.
Pertussis, Tetanus, Tifterie, Bustrix.
Man sollte die Senioren auch impfen, weil es wird häufig nicht diagnostiziert.
Interessant. Wie alt muss man diese Impfung machen?
Es wird in Polen ab 60.
Super. Vielen Dank für die Informationen.
Er ist verheiratet und habe zwei Erwachsene-Kinder, die beide gesund sind.
Er wohnt mit seiner Frau zusammen.
Was ist Ihre Verdachtstiagnose?
Die anamnestische Angaben deuten am ersten auf.
Genomini.
Aber differenzial diagnostisch.
Natürlich Lungen, Bruncherkrebs, COPD.
Und Absäß in den rechtseitigen Pulmenbereich.
Rechtseitige dem Erden.
Absäß.
Die Embolie kann ich nicht denken.
Sie brauchen nur durch zwei Differenzialdiagnosen.
Das reicht aus.
Wir haben den Verdacht auf eine Brontiopneumonie.
Brontiopneumonie würde ich einfach nur sagen.
Brontiopneumonie rechts in Höhe der Skapula.
Dort eventuell eine ex-Azerbierte, fieberhafte Brontitis.
Man muss wahrscheinlich sagen, der Patient hat eine COPD.
Die ist bisher noch nicht diagnostiziert worden.
Aber es spricht viel dafür.
Er hat im Winter jetzt zu den Infekt-Ex-Azerbationen.
Er ist starker, langjährig.
Ein Karzinom hat keine Gewichtsabnahme.
Aber die Familie-Anlage hat er.
Ich sehe hier unten auch, hier steht Pleuritis.
Das würde den inspiratorischen Schmerz erklären.
Eine Begleitpleuritis.
Wenn die Pleura reibt, das ist schmerzhaft.
Die Patienten wollen gar nicht tief die Inspiration.
Die tiefe Inspiration ist schmerzhaft.
Oder der starke Husten.
Es ist sicherlich eine wahrscheinlich Brontiopneumonie mit Begleitpleuritis.
Das ist der differentialdiagnostisch ex-Azerbierte Brontitis.
Bei COPD wahrscheinlich Brontialkarzinom.
Man macht Bildgebung jetzt.
Man schaut.
Das glaube ich nicht.
Ich wünsche es dem Patienten, dass er kein Brontialkarzinom hat.
Sondern nur eine Brontiopneumonie.
Es ist für einen 60-jährigen Patienten 39 Grad fieber.
Das ist sehr belastend für ihn.
Gut, das haben Sie gut gemacht.
Sie haben das sehr gut strukturiert.
Sie haben das gut verstanden.
Sie haben viele Fachbegriffe gekonnt.
Sie kennen die Fachbegriffe eigentlich alle.
Sie müssen sie nur dann auch sagen.
Und nicht sagen, an Lungenkrebs verstorben.
Versuchen Sie dann Brontialkarzinom oder pulmonales Karzinom.
Insgesamt haben Sie das sehr gut gemacht.
Jetzt habe ich Sie schon mal gefragt, wann Sie Ihre Prüfung machen.
18. Dezember.
Das müssen wir richtige Diagenose stellen.
Deswegen habenoine gesagt, weil dann die Diagenose recht.
Aber wer Sie nicht die richtige Diagenose sagen kann,
dass sie nicht verstehen kann.
Echt?
Es ist aber eigentlich eine Fachspracheprüfung oder ein Facharztprüfung?
Das gibt es.
alles gut gemacht, sie sprechen sehr gut, aber sie haben keine richtige Diagnose
stellen. Ja, aber Sie haben bisher doch nur die
Anamnese erhoben und aufgrund einer Anamnese kann man zwar schon eine
Diagnose sehr gut eingrenzen und sagen zu 80 Prozent kann das eine Plenumonie
sein, aber sie brauchen doch für die Absicherung der Diagnose auch noch
eine körperliche Untersuchung, ganz wichtig und dann ergänzend eine
operative Laboruntersuchung, das sind ja die Säulen.
Ja. Jetzt nur zu sagen, Sie haben keine richtige Diagnose gestellt, aufgrund
der Anamnese finde ich schon. Ja, das ist nicht gut, oder?
Das ist nicht gut. Sagen Sie, ich habe den Verdacht, die Verdachtsdiagnose,
Brontioproemie, Differenzialdiagnostisch bieten Sie zwei an,
normalerweise sind zwei in Ordnung, Sie müssen jetzt nicht noch sagen,
Lungenembolie und so, das müssen Sie glaube ich nicht sagen.
Ich weiß, dass Münster, ich bin selber in der Ärztekammer Münster als
Mitgliedte, ich weiß, dass die da auch sehr eigenartig sind, aber
das kann ich mir nicht vorstellen. Sie sind selbstbewusst, Sie können
das sehr gut erklären.
Danke.
Lasst Sie sich keine Angst machen.
Okay.